[Applaudissements]
bonjour hilda 38 38 ans et 12 jours il
m'est arrivé une chance incroyable je
suis né dans une famille formidable
aimante et surtout dans un pays de
liberté et en paix est un pays de droit
on oublie bien souvent depuis je vais
pas dire que je n'ai pas eu de chance
mais je dirais pas non plus que j'en ai
eu
j'ai tout simplement construit ma vie
petit à petit en fait je crois par la
chance je crois en dessin et je crois
que sous serment
nous sommes maîtres de notre destin les
hasards de la vie font qui nous arrive
des choses bien mal mais je suis
convaincu que nous sommes les seuls à
décider de ce que nous en faisons de ces
événements qui nous arrive
j'ai décidé d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
pour vous présenter ma méthode pour
atteindre mes objectifs
et pour vous prouver que la chance n'a
rien à voir avec tout ça ma méthode elle
se décompose en trois points le premier
point c'est de fixer votre rêve un
endroit bien précis dans votre tête vous
voyez pour le moment nous sommes là et
je fixe mon objectif bien non tout là
haut
évidemment ça n'arrive jamais qu'on
puisse y aller
en une ligne tout droite toute simple ce
serait trop facile et ce serait pas
drôle non
en fait pour atteindre cet objectif tous
les chemins sont possibles et un coup à
gauche un coup à droite
finalement l'objectif site de
l'atteindre
ce rêve peu importe les chemins que l'on
emprunte d'accord le souci c'est que
vous le voyez la courbe n'est pas
toujours ascendante
régulièrement elle est descendante ce
sont les hasards de la vie qui font que
parfois il nous arrive des choses qui ne
sont pas vraiment positive
et toutes ces petites choses qui nous
arrive ce chemin qu'on emprunte un coup
à gauche un coup à droite un coup en bas
un couloir où vont nous faire changer
notre vision des choses et du coup cet
objectif qu'on s'était fixés eh ben il
nous sort un petit peu dépassé plus
vraiment en accord avec la perception
que l'on a des choses
quel est le problème mais il y aura pas
de problème
regardez je les fasse et je refais un
autre une robe plus bas plus haut peu
importe c'est votre vie c'est vous qui
décidez de ce que vous voulez faire de
vos objectifs de vos rêves
je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote quand j'ai commencé en école de
commerce en première année j'ai
découvert le marketing
j'ai grandi en afrique de l'ouest
marketing je vous avoue que vraiment
c'était quelque chose qui n'était pas
vraiment bien mis en avant dans les
entreprises on va dire et donc tout
naturellement pour cette première année
où nous devions réaliser un stage de 6
mois environ
j'avais envoyé tous les cv pour des
postes d'assistant chef de produit
assistant chef de rayon assistant
commercial en grandes et moyennes
surfaces
le rêve et puis patatras
un mois et demi avant le démarrage de ce
stage accident de moto muscle de la
cuisse sectionner les ouverte
le cartilage du genou envolée j'aurai
pour six semaines d'athènes sans pouvoir
poser de carter dans ces circonstances
comment vous dire galoper dans les
rayons ou volant d'une voiture pour
aller vendre des canettes d'une boisson
bien connu ce n'était plus vraiment
d'actualité
et le voilà donc dans mon lit d'hôpital
le dire
pas possible comment vais-je faire moi
qui voulais faire du marketing
qu'est ce que je vais faire de mon stage
en fait j'avais pas envoyer tous mes cv
dans ce sens j'avais envoyé aussi mon cv
à un transitaire qui avait eu la
gentillesse de me prendre en job d'été
l'année précédente alors l'émission
c'était mais sous pli édition de
factures classement des dossiers etc que
des choses assez futile en soi mais qui
donne un sérieux coup de main en cette
période estivale où la plupart des gens
sont en congé je m'étais entendu avec à
peu près tout le monde et ça c'était
relativement bien passé pour ne pas dire
très bien passé et donc je suis dans ma
chambre d'hôpital il n'y avait pas de
portable à l'époque donc je décroche le
téléphone sur la table de nuit et
j'appelle ce transitaires et la chose au
hasard
moi je préfère dire hasard il se trouve
que cette entreprise devait recruter une
assistante commerciale et donc le
directeur me dit écoutez plutôt que de
recruter quelqu'un tout de suite
vous connaissez déjà l'entreprise vous
connaissez déjà tout le monde je vous
prends pour votre stage de 6 mois
écoutez ça a été une révélation le monde
s'est ouvert à main c'est pas compliqué
j'étais en contact avec l'indonésie la
malaisie l'inde
gd des entreprises françaises à se
rendre visible sur le fun seafood show
de new york
une révélation je vous dis fini mon
objectif marketing j'ai décidé de faire
du commerce international ma vie tout
simplement
c'est pas fini mon histoire de joux
l'année suivante j'ai décidé de faire
une année de césure et deux pour essayer
d'avoir un petit peu plus d'expérience
dans ce métier du commerce international
assez rapidement un prof de mon école
med avec son réseau et on me propose un
stage chez un transitaire toujours à
miami le rêve le rêve
oui sauf que il était toujours là je
suis là et en l'occurrence il fallait
que je fasse une opération à 6
lourdes pour pouvoir espérer refaire un
petit peu de crapahutage le sport et en
tous genres un jour j'avais donc le
choix entre miami mais plus de genoux ou
le havre super mais un jeune et j'ai
choisi le havre le havre si tu m'entends
eh ben je le regrette pas du tout ça a
été d'abord une année exceptionnelle
dans une compagnie maritime qui m'a
offert après mon premier job et dans
cette entreprise
eh ben j'ai rencontré l'homme de bélie
alors est ce que c'est une chance
d'avoir eu cet accident en moto
j'ai un petit peu de mal à dire ça quand
même un hasard oui un malheureux hasard
mais en tout cas ça a bouleversé ma vie
et pas qu'en mal j'ai décidé de de
rebondir j'ai pris mon destin en main et
pas finalement mon destin pour le moment
en tout cas jusqu'ici tout va bien comme
on dit donc vous l'aurez compris mon
premier point s'est fixé vous votre
objectif et gardez le en vous vous êtes
le seul maître de votre rêve et c'est
vous qui décidez de le transformer à
votre guise cela ne regarde personne
d'autre
le deuxième point est bien c'est votre
entourage
je sais pas si vous avez vu le dessin
animé deux autos pia zotto pia est passé
l'histoire d'une petite la quine qui
rêve de devenir policier
le problème c'est que ce métier est
destiné aux gros animaux dans son
univers mais c'est pas grave elle décide
quand même de s'inscrire à l'école de
police et la voilà qui est traîné dans
la boue qui n'arrive à rien à côté de
ces rhinocéros éléphants et j'en passe
gros animaux et
et donc on voit évidemment tous ces
événements qui se déroulent dans cette
école de police jusqu'à l'examen final
où elle se retrouve face à un immense
mur d'escaladé et vous l'aurez compris
il faut absolument qu'elles atteignent
le sourire est là dans un élan de
l'ambition la voilà qui rebondit et qui
saute de tête en tête un coup sûr les
noces et rançonne que sur l'éléphant et
elle arrive ainsi jusqu'au sommet mon
fils m'a dit mais la triche est
maintenant non garçon elle a su
s'appuyer sur des personnes compétentes
et digne de confiance
moi ce que je veux en venir en fait
regardez autour de vous y'a pas que
votre famille et vos amis qui peuvent
vous aider
tout le monde ici est à même de pouvoir
vous aider dans un an dans l'atteinte de
vos objectifs et de vos rêves je vais
vous raconter une autre petite anecdote
vous en doutez il ya de ça à peu près
quatre ans pour se balader avec mon mari
et mon fils au marché de noël de
l'éperon et là on voit un stand avec des
portraits de paysages des comores j'ai
été émue par ces portraits je me suis
arrêté et j'ai longuement discuté avec
la photographe qui présentait ses
oeuvres je discute assez souvent ça
m'arrive
et puis mon mari a remarqué et quand je
suis partie du stand
il y est retourné et quelques jours plus
tard au pied du sapin j'avais une
enveloppe avec l'écrit bon pour un stage
photo avec marie-pierre le hasard encore
celui là le hasard de la vie a fait que
le stage n'a pas pu démarrer tout de
suite faute de participants mais c'est
pas grave en l'occurrence dans cette
même période
je commençais à me poser des questions
c'est vrai j'avais un très bon job c'est
vrai dans une très bonne entreprise avec
un salaire plus qu'honorable mais je
sais pas il me manquait quelque chose
j'avais envie de me lancer et une idée
commencer
armée comme ça et le stage photo
commencent trois demi journées la
première à s'occuper des loups à parler
d'ouverture de lumière de postures etc
et puis la deuxième séance nous décidons
de tous partir en voiture sur la
saline-les-hauts pour prendre en photo
une jolie casse créole et dans la
voiture du coup on commence à parler de
nous et l'américaine me dit et toi et
louise qu'est ce que tu veux faire
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie ah ben
moi je suis dans la logistique et des
approvisionnements mais je ne rêve que
j'aimerais bien changer de vie je
m'interroge et j'aimerais me lancer dans
la formation
gros plan dans la voiture elle recquiert
me regardent avec un sourire et me dit
tu sais qu'ils sachent de l'udc
aujourd'hui qu'il était sur la banquette
arrière
non je vaux luxe et jean-luc qua non
j'ai voulu que c'est le directeur d'un
des plus gros centres de formation
privés lille est donc aujourd'hui comme
étant sa carte et il dit bah écoute la
semaine prochaine le pas soit un coup de
fil je recevrai et puis tu me raconteras
un petit peu quels sont tes projets et
donc voilà la semaine suivante j'ai été
voir jean-luc on à échanger et à la fin
de cet entretien il se proposait si je
passais le cas de quitter mon entreprise
de me faire travailler sur quelques
modules tout heureuse j'appelle
marie-pierre seppois jean-luc ça a
marché
super t'aurais pas quelques conseils à
me donner et oui parce que mary kerr
elle n'est pas seulement photographe et
formatrice en photo marie cavada est
aussi formatrice tout court dans des
différents domaines qui intéressent les
entreprises
pas de problème je dit écoute c'est très
gentil à toi si tu veux je t'invite au
resto on se fait un petit déjeuner ça me
ferait plaisir
et pendant ce déjeuner et bien
marie-pierre me donne donc quelques
conseils et elle me propose de me
présenter à quelques personnes de son
réseau en qui elle a confiance
elle me dit en substance et que tu
donnes moi deux semaines j'appelle de
trois personnes
et tu les appelles dans deux semaines je
pense qu'il te recevons mois parfois je
dérape parfois j'oublie deux semaines
après j'ai téléphoné à norman qui me
recevait je pense par sympathie
vis-à-vis de marie-pierre sauf que le
bal le contact fabien habillé bien passé
et deux mois plus tard il me confiait
des modules dans le sud puis après dans
le nord de l'île voilà comment c'est
fait à peu près la moitié de mon
portefeuille clients aujourd'hui c'est
une chance est ce que c'est une chance
que j'ai un super mari qui m'offre un
bon pour un stage photo
non je vais reprendre ce qu'a dit la
jeune femme en entrée c'est pas une
chance je les choisis vous marie il m'a
un peu choisit aussi est ce que c'est
une chance que j'aime la photo est ce
que c'est une chance que jean-luc
hamelin photo dans le hasard c'est que
nous ayons été réuni tous les trois
marie luc et moi et les autres je les
oublie pas évidemment dans cette
formation et je me suis dévoilé j'ai dit
ce que je voulais faire
alors que j'en avais que par les a
quasiment personne encore vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point votre
entourage peut vous aider
faites confiance aux gens vous
réaliserez une chose c'est que quand
vous accorder votre confiance à
quelqu'un il s'en sent honorée et de cet
honneur que je voulais fait il a envie
de sortir quelque chose pour vous il a
envie de se dépasser pour vous en tout
cas c'est ce que je ressens
peut-être que je vis dans le monde des
bisounours mais je vous assure vous en
êtes tous des bisous et je suis sûr que
vous m'aiderez et j'aimerais vraiment
briller mais aussi donc premier point
prenez votre objectif maîtriser le
déplacer le à votre guise et deuxième
point n'hésitez pas à parler autour de
vous de ce que vous voulez rire
ces gens vient vous troisième point en
troisième point c'est qu'en fait elle
pas qu'un seul objectif dans ma petite
tête y en a une lui et dans ma tête ça
ressemble un ciel étoilé
il y en a des professionnels vient d'un
des personnels il y en a des très hauts
il y en a des très bas pourquoi et bien
tout simplement parce que pour atteindre
cet objectif qu'ils you je vais faire
comme la petite latine dans son auto pia
quand je vais rebondir de tête en tête
et tous ses objectifs que je vais
atteindre petit à petit vont me donner
confiance
vous avez besoin d'avoir confiance en
vous pour avancer dans la vie alors
pensez régulièrement avons fixé des
objectifs de rien du tout mais qui vous
font vous sentir bien
alors qu'est ce que c'est quand je me
suis entraîné pour ce stade j'ai mon ami
qui m'a dit il faut que tu donnes un
exemple je suis dit mais n'ont cessé que
des petites choses insignifiantes
oui mais justement parce que c'est
insignifiant
c'est ça toute leur importance est là il
faut que tu en parles
alors je vais vous le dire s'est passé
un petit peu de temps avec mon fils
s'est passé un moment seul avec mon mari
sait voir les amis que j'aime c'est
prendre le temps de m'asseoir sur la
varangue avec une belle musique et puis
un petit mot bondi verre de vin à la
main et de regarder le coucher du soleil
c'est toutes ces petites choses là alors
ça paraît bizarre d'appeler ça des
objectifs mais on vit tellement à 100 à
l'heure dans notre société que c'est un
véritable objectif de prendre le temps
de faire toutes ces petites choses de
rien du tout et on s'y sent tellement
bien quand on y arrive et puis tous ces
petits objectifs
ils ont un autre une autre raison d'être
aussi c'est que il faut bien l'avouer
parfois vous est fixé un objectif majeur
et vous n'arrivez pas à l'atteindre
vous allez vous empruntez tous les
chemins de la terre y a rien à faire
vous n'y arrivez pas c'est pas une
question de chance de lazard c'est c'est
la vie c'est tout ça me ferait mal de
dents ça vous fait mal dehors et vous
aurez peut-être énormément de mal
relever si vous arrivez à vous fixer des
toutes petites choses de rien du tout
petit à petit vous arriverez à vous
relever et à jour fixé des objectifs qui
vous donneront envie de vivre
je voudrais juste vous rappeler une
chose c'est que la vie en soi est un
rêve
ne l'oubliez pas merci
[Applaudissements]